We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two David Pakman.
We got a voicemail late last week about this
new March 4th thing. There are Kuhnen people
who I don't even know that. I can say
they believe it. They are saying maybe
they believe it. Kuhnen people are
now saying that through some kind of
bizarre technicality, Donald Trump is going
to resume his presidency on March 4th.
And I said, isn't this in some sense mental
illness? Delusional in a way? And a caller left
me a voicemail saying it is. But there is also
some of that on the left. Let's take a listen.
The latest March 4th Kuhnen
thing, let's call it what it is,
it's mental illness, OK, but the Democrats
are also. Guilty of having mental illness.
They think this is the Wizard of Oz,
where at some point the Republicans
are going to discover that they had a brain.
The whole time I had courage, the whole time
they had conscience. The whole time they just
didn't know it. Right. It was there all along.
Well, guess what else? That's never
going to happen because they don't
have courage. They don't have conscience and
they don't have a brain. And this March 4th
Bible is mental illness. And I would propose
that to give it any media attention at all,
even on admittedly an anti and on
YouTube progressive channel still
gives it a voice that it doesn't deserve.
All right. So there is a big admonishment
there. But no, I think that the what
I what I completely agree with is,
you know, throughout the Trump fur law, for
decades, honestly, it happened during George W.
Bush kept happening. But certainly during the
Trump presidency, there would be this sense where,
oh, whoa, whoa, this is too much. Even the
Trump and lunatics aren't going to defend this.
Clearly, Republican senators are now going
to say this is too far. And, of course,
it never happened. And it is, in a sense,
insanity to keep repeating the same expectation
absent any evidence that should make us think
this is too far, this is too low even for
Republicans to say no, it never is. It never
is. And I do think that that's an important,
important take away.
And the caller is absolutely right
on the bonus show today, House impeachment
managers are defending their decision not to
call witnesses in the Trump impeachment trial
after they voted to call witnesses. That's one
story. Number two, Joe Biden is launching a review
of the Guantanamo Bay detention center and he is
planning to close it before leaving office.
We're still doing this. Yes, we're still
talking about closing Gitmo. Maybe Joe Biden
can get it done and Parla is back again. It's
like the website that just won't die. Parla
is back again. We'll talk a little bit about
the latest iteration and what impact
it's having on the conservative dialog.
I guess we would call it all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Get
instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom, Ilesha. That.